hello everybody i'm sorry i haven't
recorded in a couple of days um i'm
graduating this week and as a result of
that it's kind of just been a lot of
mayhem here on my end
and it hasn't been easy to you know kind
of find time to actually set aside and
make new content i mean there's that in
conjunction with the fact that there's
really not too much left for me to talk
about you know i can start talking about
some really complicated distributed
systems topics but
you know at the end of the day even
though i like talking about that stuff
this is more of a systems design prep
channel more so than just a super you
know theoretical distributed systems
channel and so i'm probably going to
post um you know today's video and then
maybe one more and i think that'll
probably uh you know kind of round out
the series for distributed systems
concepts and from there we can start
doing actual interview questions which i
hope to start in early june so hopefully
that gives you a sense of kind of where
the channel is at but without further
ado let's talk about some graph
databases
okay neo4j what is it well basically a
ton of data these days is best
represented in a graphical format that
might be something like facebook friend
relationships map data on google maps or
even something like the page rank
algorithm and web crawler links so
basically a bunch of databases have kind
of popped up to better process this data
where you're not necessarily going and
scanning a bunch of rows in a table to
kind of fit some nodes that match a
bunch of properties but rather you're
trying to find all of these nodes that
have really complex relationships within
the data and deeply nested data that you
know you have to be able to
deeply query through some sort of
breadth or depth first search in order
to gain insights on it so the graph
database that we're going to be talking
about today is neo4j because they've
kind of been spearheading the graph
database
you know kind of movement and they have
a very unique architecture
so
generally speaking looking at the data
format in a graph we have a bunch of
different types of nodes nodes can hold
properties which don't have to
necessarily follow any certain format
it's kind of like nosql in that sense we
are you know free in our schema and then
a bunch of relationships which is kind
of the bread and butter of the graphs in
the sense that relationships are
directed edges on the nodes which
themselves can have
labels which act as a useful property in
querying
okay in terms of native and non-native
graph databases well basically
a good subset of graph databases are
known as something that aren't
non-native which means that they're
basically abstractions built upon
existing data stores like i don't know
cassandra or perhaps even a relational
database system
and what those do are they basically
give you a graph querying language but
at the end of the day the data is stored
in the same way that you know i've kind
of discussed on this channel so far you
know in a typical type of indexing
system
however
on the contrary neo4j is what's known as
a native graph database in the sense
that it stores the data on disk in this
different format which i'm going to
explain in the subsequent slides and by
doing so it is much better able to
support graph queries and achieve higher
throughput
so
basically nodes relationships labels and
properties are all going to be stored in
different sets of files
and all of these files are effectively
just going to be linked lists so what
type of data are we storing in these
linked lists well the linked lists are
going to give us the disk address from
you know say one node to its
corresponding relationships or one
relationship to the next relationship
on the same starting node and by doing
this we can quickly run all of these
queries because
as opposed to you know a traditional
database where you basically have to go
ahead and hit an index every single time
you want to find all of the you know
related nodes or anything like that by
using this linked list we're basically
just running a disk traversal and using
all of these disk pointers with
hopefully relatively adjacent data in
order to get very fast performance
so for example each node has a pointer
to its first relationship
and then the first relationship has a
pointer to the second relationship from
that starting node and then onwards and
onwards and onwards
this is what's known as index free
adjacency and index free adjacency is
why neo4j is able to achieve very fast
performance
so
why is it so important that we aren't
using an index here
well basically if all nodes are being
added to an index what this means is
that finding a node in an index is going
to scale logarithmically with that so
for huge graphs we have to basically run
a binary search every single time on the
index and if we're running all of these
binary searches that is log n with
respect to the number of nodes in a
graph and as a result
even if the the query itself that we're
making is relatively small by virtue of
having to go through this index every
single time we are incurring a huge
performance hit on the other hand by not
having to use an index for our graph
database
and neo4j specifically we can basically
ensure that the actual time it takes to
run a given query is directly
proportional to the number of nodes that
are actually being touched in that graph
query
like i said an index here is basically
just going to be
adding an extra step to a graph query
it's like having to hit a phone book
every single time that you want to go
from one node to the other because you
have to find where on disk that second
node is and as a result of that
huge graphs are going to have to you
know you have to go through that phone
book every single time it's going to
take forever and so it's really
important to actually be able to avoid
indexes
so
what are some challenges with actually
having to use graph data well for
starters
the fact that we're no longer storing
things in an index means that we have
all of these you know different files
where they're referencing one another
and as a result it's really important
that we can actually run transactions
and have all these acid properties the
reason for this being we can easily get
an inconsistent graph if say you know we
were to change one edge of the graph and
then didn't change the corresponding
nodes on each side of the edge and
having an inconsistent graph would be
hugely impactful and very bad for you
know the correctness of our data that
would be you know extremely problematic
so neo4j basically you know does acid
properties in a pretty typical fashion
with isolation being implemented via
two-phase locking and then atomicity
being done using a right ahead log
this also even becomes more of a
challenge on a distributed scale because
imagine i have two nodes on different
partitions in a cluster and then i have
to go ahead and change the edge between
them and now i have to change two nodes
and we've run into a two-phase commit
problem
so like i said if we have basically a
bunch of isolated transactions and
they're touching different partitions or
actually the same partitions we have to
be able to make sure that all the
partitions agree on the ordering of
those transactions and so
obviously this requires something like
two-phase commit again but as a kind of
cool optimization to two-phase commit
what neo4j actually does is it will only
use two-phase commit on you know two
different transactions if it's the case
that they overlap in some partition so
this allows them to make sure that
they're not having all of this
coordination overhead every single time
we have
basically um you know some sort of
distributed transaction and by avoiding
all that coordination overhead in you
know kind of the general majority of
cases and only having to do it in the
minority of cases they're able to keep
relatively high throughput even when
distributing a graph over a large scale
and then additionally just for
replication neo4j uses raft
okay so in conclusion graph databases
are super
popular recently because there is so
much data that can be represented as a
graph and
basically the only big limitation up to
this point has been the way that we've
modeled our data in the past it's really
not efficient to use something like a
relational database management system to
do a multi-layer graph query sure joins
for like a one-layer graph query are
fine but the second you really want to
do all sorts of deep traversals it
really doesn't make sense anymore and as
a result graph databases are growing
super quickly and they've allowed us to
gain tons of insight into our data and
do all sorts of complicated queries
um obviously being able to kind of
remove the index which seemed like such
a fundamental uh you know kind of
structure to all databases
it almost seems controversial at first
but when you really think about it it
makes a lot of sense in the graph use
case so i think it's kind of cool to see
how these graph databases work and i
hope this video was useful i think i'm
going to have probably one more in this
systems design concept series and then
we can start getting to practice
problems have a good one guys